hey
you ever wonder about
superconductivity with possibly one of
the most important scientific
breakthroughs of the 21st century it was
claimed to Herald a Monumental
breakthrough some are calling it The
Holy Grail of chips a superconductor
[Music]
you might have heard about conducting
materials metal is a commonly used
conductor copper is relatively
inexpensive it's bendable so you can
make wires out of it and basically
electrons move through the copper
and it carries electricity
but you need a force
to make that happen you need a voltage
that will drive a current okay
so as the electrons move through the
medium because it doesn't have to be
copper it could be gold gold is a nice
conductor of electricity if it conducts
as the electron moves it gets resistance
from the material itself
and that resistance
slows down the current if it eats it
what does it then do with it it heats up
the wire or the wire gets hot so for
many circuits if you feel the wires
after a time they feel warm
this is electrical resistance
to the movement of those electrons
sometimes you want resistance and we've
made electrical components
hold resistors
this enables you to change the current
from one place to another because not
all current is useful in all places
so circuit boards have all manner of
circuit components and it includes
resistors for just this purpose
for some materials
there exists a temperature
below which
and it happens abruptly a temperatures
cold enough that below that temperature
all resistance drops to zero
you could take away
the battery that's driving a voltage and
whatever current was there will stay in
the wire forever
with no loss
of current
that is super conductivity
so superconductivity is something you
would want driving an electrical grid
with no loss of current
this lost current moving electricity
from one place to another and so if you
could embed the entire electrical system
in a very cold vat of liquid nitrogen
and you made all of your wires
out of a material that would go
superconducting at the temperature of
liquid nitrogen we would have no current
losses anywhere
but who wants to live in liquid nitrogen
okay
liquid at what temperature is 70 degrees
Kelvin
all right if you dipped a banana in
liquid nitrogen and pulled it out a
minute later it'll and you could hit it
with a hammer it'll shatter by the way
those would be high temperature
superconductors
at that cold temperature those are high
temperatures because most of the
traditional super conductors don't go
superconducting until they are down
around 10 degrees
Calvin five degrees Kelvin three degrees
Kelvin okay
and that's cold no you can't walk around
with something that's four degrees
Kelvin oh by the way officially we don't
use the term degree referring to Kelvin
it's just four kelvins but I'm letting
I'm reminding you that they are
temperatures so why is that cold because
zero Kelvin is the coldest possible
temperature you can get it's the
absolute temperature scale zero on the
absolute scale has no negative
temperatures
right that is the coldest you can
possibly be
so there's a hunt for a room temperature
superconductor
the problem is many of them are made of
ceramic the ones that are approaching
room temperature and ceramic it tends to
be brittle uh our electrical system is
made of wires that bend and go around
corners and through conduits and pipes
and up into your equipment and into
circuit boards ceramic as a way of
breaking if you bend it at all
so it is not clear
how we would use ceramic superconductors
in our culture
relative to how we've been using
electricity to this day
it's not clear how one would replace the
other or maybe we'd have to invent a
whole new way of thinking about
electrical components so that it's no
longer in the context of wires I don't
know
but it is a frontier of materials
physics
and the industrial applications in
controlled settings aren't Limitless
the question is whether it is portable
to all of society
so another feature of superconductivity
is
that it rejects all magnetic fields so
what you can do a thing where you have a
magnet attached to metal and it's
attracted to it and then you drop the
temperature of that metal below its own
superconducting
threshold and at that point the magnetic
field that had been penetrating it gets
rejected out of it and the magnet then
begins to float on top of it
by the way
in Texas Waxahachie Texas we began
digging a hole to build the largest
particle collider in the world
that was going to use
superconducting materials
for the magnetic field
that would be accelerating the charged
particles to make the most powerful
particle accelerator in the world and it
was called the superconducting super
collider the initial funding began in
the 1980s under President Reagan
and then early 90s
Congress cut the budget
and the center of mass of particle
physics moved to Europe to Switzerland
to the the European Center for nuclear
research CERN is there is there acronym
and they then made the next round of
discoveries
not us
here in the United States oh why did we
cut the funding or if you look at the
report it says oh it's cost overruns
can't cost this because oh yeah really
really oh like really
what else happened in like 1989 19 oh
peace broke out in Europe
that's what happened the Cold War ended
oh gone is the funding for the physics
that we have so thoroughly funded for
the entire 20th century so no the report
doesn't say peace broke out we don't
need physicists anymore no it doesn't
say that
but that happened right around that time
just saying
so all right so that would have been a
scientific application fully exploiting
super conducting materials
to make the most powerful magnetic field
you can to accelerate the particles and
make the most powerful Atom Smasher the
world had ever seen
anyhow that's what's up with that this
has been uh Star Talk
Neil deGrasse Tyson you're a personal
astrophysicist with another what's up
with that
[Music]